let's open up the mailbag sources close
to me tell me that we are indeed live
today for the full hour on sky sports
nfl so how about a question for one of
our most loyal
viewers listeners and readers he's been
around for a long time a red zone alk
we've gotten questions from him back
when we did pft live only as a digital
enterprise he's been around for a long
time and we appreciate his input do the
texans he asks have time on their side
when it comes to placating desean watson
shireen look i see it as a very simple
proposition they got to figure out a
plan and they need to implement it march
17. that's the start of the new league
year because if there's other teams out
there trying to figure out what they're
going to do at quarterback
they're going to be reluctant to put the
brakes on their efforts to work a trade
sign a free agent do whatever if they're
sitting around waiting to see what
happens with desean watson i don't think
time is on the texan side i think they
got a lot to do and in the grand scheme
of things they don't have a lot of time
to figure it out
i think the enemy is emerging possibly
as the favorite there we know he's on
their list and i would think he would at
least be a finalist who they would talk
to so we're talking about them getting a
head coach mike
assuming the chiefs win that's going to
come after the super bowl even if it's
not i think leslie fraser is probably
going to be a finalist too so one of
those two teams has a guy that the
texans are interested in so i think
we're looking at this hire being made
after the super bowl at that point they
have to move quickly that coach has to
meet with deshaun watson if he's smart
he meets with deshaun watson before he
ever takes that job to assure himself
that deshaun watson's going to be his
quarterback if he's not i'm not sure i
take that job but once they do that
they've got to get either desean watson
on board or to the point of okay we're
going to open this up to a bidding war
get all those teams who are interested
in desean watson make it known give us
your best offer and hit them against
each other as you've said mike
yeah and there's a flow chart that
definitely needs to be constructed you
and i can figure that out yesterday
miles simmons and i were talking about
it the imperative nature of getting
deshawn watson on board with an eric b
enemy before be enemy signs the contract
and you get the two of them in a room if
i'm the enemy i'm not taking this job
until i talk to desean watson can you
set it up i want to talk to him and i
want to know is he on board i want his
word before i take it so on the flow
chart that ends it there's there's
nothing to discuss if deshaun watson is
on board and has changed his mind and
doesn't want out but the other side of
the flow chart you know that's the short
little will desean stay yes and
the other side is where it can go a
bunch of different ways and they need to
be smart about anticipating how the
dominoes can fall and when they need to
move and how they need to craft a market
and there's a sweet spot there somewhere
where they get fair value but also
deshawn watson doesn't feel like he's
going to a team that after that team
gives up what it gives up to get to sean
watson it's going to be four and 12
right while he has a great year too then
how has he improved his situation
yeah that's exactly right mike and he's
got that control with the no trade
clause he can tell the texans these are
the teams i will go to work it out with
one of these teams
all right ian's for 79 asks haven't the
dolphins spent the last 18 months trying
to rebuild the roster why would they
want to give away most of their draft
capital for the next three years for a
quarterback as good as desean watson is
when they've still got gaps in their
current roster you don't have to give
away most of your draft capital for the
next three years i think three first
round picks if watson decides he's out
i think offering back to houston the
third overall pick that would have been
theirs anyway but for the laramie tunzel
trade plus miami's other first round
pick plus the first round pick next year
is enough to get to sean watson and when
you think about it
in terms of making an investment of
draft picks if you're
the dolphins and you say
i'm using my first round pick
and getting to sean watson
how much more beyond my first round pick
am i willing to give up to know
that i'm getting because otherwise i
could take a quarterback with my first
round pick and he's not gonna be any
good like maybe two it turns out being
so it's easy to justify multiple first
round picks and maybe a third one but i
don't think it guts your roster and i
think the dolphins one of the few teams
shireen best suited to make the trade
that will make the texans happy and
still have a good team moving forward
i think it would make the texas happy
and i think it would make deshaun watson
happy based on reports that we've heard
i will ask you this mike if you're the
texans do you want tua if you're the
dolphins do you want to give them to her
don't i haven't seen enough from two at
a want to i'd rather have the draft
picks i'd rather have number three
overall and try to take a quarterback
than take two and two further first
round picks and sims and i were talking
about that today you know this may be so
complicated at the end of the day it's a
three-team deal because it could be yeah
that
the team that wants desean watson has a
quarterback that someone else wants more
than the texans would want him this came
up in the context of the possibility of
the raiders doing the deal because i can
guarantee you the texans don't want
anyone named carr playing quarterback
for them ever again even if it's spelled
different so
maybe someone else gets derek carr and
that someone else throws in a draft pick
and it go and it all factors in that way
it could be that this one is so big and
so complex it takes three teams so maybe
there's another team out there that
would love to have tua if the texans
look at it and say that's not the guy
that we want being our franchise
quarterback
and we don't see many of those three
team trades mike so that would be
interesting if that were to happen
and remember even though the trades
can't occur until 4 pm eastern on march
the 17th the start of the new league
year the deals can be worked out it
happened just a couple of years ago when
alex smith was traded alex to washington
clearing out the spot uh in kansas city
for patrick mahomes and then making it
clear that kirk cousins wouldn't be back
in signing with minnesota but that deal
was done weeks before it became official
it could happen in theory it could
happen at any time so we'll continue to
watch that story real quickly on the way
out the door philly jj philly should the
lions trade matthew stafford and what
value do you see getting back for them
they brad holmes a new gm has said he's
going to look at the whole roster no
guarantees for stafford no guarantee he
wants to even be there
i think it would be great mike for
matthew stafford to start over somewhere
else and i think it would be the lions
great for them to get a new start with
the new quarterback the problem is
obviously we're pacing him you got to
find somebody better
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports